if you have a problem with your thyroid
gland your doctor may recommend a
robotic thyroidectomy your thyroid gland
is located over your larynx or voice box
it wraps around your trachea or windpipe
your thyroid produces a hormone called
thyroid hormone and secretes it directly
into your bloodstream
your body uses thyroid hormone to
increase your energy and raise your body
temperature when necessary for example
these effects help offset the heat your
body loses when exposed to cold weather
your doctor may recommend a robotic
thyroidectomy if you have certain
thyroid cancers an enlargement of the
gland called a goiter
or benign nodules
along with having these conditions you
may be considered for a robotic
thyroidectomy if you are at a healthy
weight
your thyroid cancer is less than an inch
in diameter your Gorder or nodules are
less than one and a half inches
and you want to avoid scars on your neck
before your procedure an intravenous
line will be started you may be given
antibiotics through the IV to decrease
your chance of infection you will be
given general anesthesia a breathing
tube will be inserted through your mouth
and down your throat to help you breathe
during the operation
your surgeon will make a small incision
in your armpit this location allows your
surgeon to reach or thyroid gland
without leaving a scar on your neck
a second small incision may be made by
your breastbone
through the armpit incision your surgeon
will create a path under the skin of
your chest and neck muscles to reach
your thyroid gland
an assistant will insert the robotic
arms with tools through the incisions
unlike standard laparoscopic instruments
these tools can rotate 360 degrees and
have more flexibility than the human
wrist
seated at a special console your surgeon
will operate the robotic arms and the
camera with joystick like controls and
foot pedals
a computer will translate the exact
movements of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools
same time a high-definition vision
system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area
with the robotic arms in position your
surgeon will carefully separate your
thyroid from the tissues around it
depending on the reason for your surgery
your surgeon will remove one lobe of
your thyroid or the entire gland
your doctor may remove nearby lymph
nodes as well
near the end of your procedure your
surgeon will put a surgical drain in
your armpit incision the drain will
remain there for several days at the end
of your procedure the tiny incisions
will be closed with stitches staples
surgical glue or closure tape dressings
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring your
surgeon may check your larynx for injury
you'll be given pain medication as
needed you may continue to receive
antibiotics through your IV most
patients are released from the hospital
one or two days after the procedure your
doctor may prescribe calcium supplements
if your entire thyroid is removed you
will take daily thyroid hormone
replacement medication